Thank you for listening to The Rest Is History. For weekly bonus episodes, ad-free listening, early access to series, and membership of our much-loved chat community, go to therestishistory.com and join the club. That is be restrained by the walls of history. We've ranged from ancient Rome to modern Washington, from Pompeii to Troy, and today we have one foot on the Great Wall of China and another on the US-Mexico border, because our subject today is walls and borders. Why do we seek to separate? Do walls work? Are they ever a good thing? Dominic Sandbrook is with me and I want to start with a wonderful, simple question we received on Twitter from the excellently named
感谢收听《历史的余烬》。要想收听每周的独家加更节目、无广告音频、抢先体验系列节目并加入我们备受喜爱的聊天社区，请访问 therestishistory.com 加入俱乐部。即便是被历史的高墙所束缚。我们的足迹从古罗马到现代华盛顿，从庞贝到特洛伊，而今天，我们的一只脚踏在中国的万里长城上，另一只脚则踏在美墨边境上，因为我们今天的主题就是墙与边境。我们为什么总想分道扬镳？墙真的有用吗？它们算是一件好事吗？多米尼克·桑德布鲁克和我在一起，我想从我们在推特上收到一个精彩而简单的问题开始，发问者是一位名字起得极好的
Tom. Tom asks, what makes a good wall? Dominic, what do you think? Golly, what makes a good wall? Well, I think golly what makes a good wall well i suppose it depends are you keeping people out or keeping people in so the emblematic wall that you and i grew up with is the berlin wall right that's the wall that we would have thought of for most of our lives when people i'd have thought of hadrian's wall would you yeah a man living in the past yeah i was much more interested in hadrian's Wall than the Berlin Wall. The Berlin Wall, of course, is actually, should probably be known as the anti-fascist protection rampart,
汤姆。汤姆问，什么样的墙才算是一堵好墙？多米尼克，你怎么看？天哪，什么样的墙才算是一堵好墙？好吧，我想说，天哪，什么样的墙才算是一堵好墙？我想这取决于你的目的是把人挡在外面还是把人关在里面。所以你和我这一代人共同经历过的最具象征意义的墙就是柏林墙，对吧？那是我们大多数人在大半生中一提到墙就会想到的，人们大概会想到哈德良长城吧？会吗？一个生活在过去的人。没错，我对哈德良长城的兴趣远大于柏林墙。当然，柏林墙实际上或许应该被称为“反法西斯防卫墙”。
which I think is a great name for a wall. I mean, I think a wall needs a good name. And the Berlin Wall had a great name. And it worked. That's the one thing people forget. I mean, the Berlin Wall was a monstrosity, but it actually did work in its purpose. Because it was set up to stop people from East Berlin fleeing into the Western sectors.
我觉得这是一个给墙起得很好的名字。我的意思是，我觉得一堵墙需要一个好名字。柏林墙就有一个好名字。而且它确实起作用了。这是人们总是忘掉的一点。我的意思是，柏林墙是个怪胎，但它在实现其目的方面确实发挥了作用。因为它建立的目的就是为了阻止东柏林人逃往西方控制区。
Right. So about three million people had fled from East Germany to West Germany between, say, 1945 and 1961 when the Berlin Wall went up. And after 1961, I think that total fell to about 5,000. About 100 people were shot. So the Berlin Wall, you know, hideous as it was, was very effective, actually. But presumably also dependent on the existence of the Iron Curtain. So the frontier running right the way across Europe, dividing the Water Pact from the native powers. Because if you don't have an Iron Curtain joining up to the Berlin Wall, you could just go round the corner of the Berlin Wall, couldn't you?
没错。因此，在大约1945年到1961年柏林墙建立之间，大约有三百万人从东德逃往西德。而在1961年之后，我记得这个数字下降到了大约5000人。大约有100人被枪杀。所以柏林墙，你知道的，尽管它很丑陋，但实际上非常有效。不过，这大概也依赖于铁幕的存在。也就是贯穿整个欧洲、将华沙条约组织与北约力量隔开的边境线。因为如果没有一道与柏林墙相连的铁幕，你完全可以绕过柏林墙的拐角，不是吗？
And that's always a problem with walls. Well, I mean, they come to an end point and then you can just go round the side. Yes, I suppose so. You're right that there was the Iron Curtain as well. So that, I guess, is going to be a theme of this episode, isn't it? Walls and borders are often the same thing. Not always the same thing, though. So Donald Trump's wall is not actually really a wall. Most of it is a fence. And there was already, you know, a fence along the US-Mexican border. So what's his status now? He's going to, I mean, as we speak, he's going to visit it.'s going to um pay a sort of uh farewell they've
而这始终是墙壁存在的一个问题。我是说，它们总有尽头，然后你就可以绕到旁边去。是的，我想是的。你说得对，当时还有铁幕。所以，我想这将会成为这一集的主题，对吧？墙壁和边境通常是一回事。不过，也并不总是完全一样。所以唐纳德·特朗普的墙实际上并不是一堵真正的墙。它大部分都是栅栏。而且美洲与墨西哥边境沿线本来就已经有了栅栏。那么他现在的状态是什么？他打算去，我的意思是，就在我们说话的时候，他正要去实地视察。他打算去……进行某种……告别访问。他们
built a tiny bit of it i think and he's going to go and say how beautiful it is and this is his great great kind of legacy but um yeah it's it's a it's not a war obviously i mean it was a ludicrous proposition that it was going to be a wall it's a fence and there were fences on the u.s border anyway but the thing with walls and fences is even the Berlin Wall, some people can get over or under them. That's the nature of borders. People cross them. Unless you're talking about North Korea,
修建了其中极小的一部分，我想，他要去宣扬这有多么美丽，这是他伟大的、伟大的某种政治遗产，但是……是的，这根本不是一堵墙。我的意思是，说那是一堵墙简直是个荒谬的命题，那是个栅栏，而且美国边境本来就有栅栏。不过关于墙和栅栏的问题是，哪怕是柏林墙，也有些人能翻过去或钻过去。这就是边境的本质。人们总是会跨越它们。除非你谈论的是朝鲜，
in which case you don't cross that wall. I mean, you get shot. Yes, I mean, that is the kind of, essentially, the iron rule that you can always break through a wall. And judging it by that standard what what would you say has been the most effective wall most effective barrier in history i don't and the only reason i'm asking you that of course is because i've got an excellent answer okay so that would make me look good why do you think okay so so my i would just tell us so i would
在这种情况下，你是不会越过那堵墙的。我的意思是，你会直接被枪毙。是的，我的意思是，这基本上就是那种铁律：你总能突破一堵墙。如果以这个标准来评判，你认为历史上最有效的墙、最有效的屏障是什么？我不知道，我之所以问你这个，当然是因为我有一个极好的答案。好吧，那这样我会显得很有面子。你觉得呢？好吧，那么——我就直说了吧。我会
say the theodosian walls do you know i've got I've got the Theodosian walls written down in front of me. Of course you have. I don't think they're effective, but they're very... They were very effective. They're built in the 5th century and they hold out till 1204. I reckon that's a pretty phenomenal record. That said, if there's one city in the world that's famous for being sacked twice, it's the city behind the theodosian war but the poor byzantines are surrounded by voracious enemies and basically
说是狄奥多西城墙。你知道吗？我面前就写着狄奥多西城墙。你当然有。我不认为它们有多有效，但它们非常……它们曾经非常有效。它们建于公元5世纪，一直坚守到1204年。我认为这是一个相当了不起的纪录。话虽如此，如果说世界上有什么城市以被洗劫过两次而闻名，那就是狄奥多西城墙背后的这座城市。不过可怜的拜占庭人被贪婪的敌人所包围，基本上
this is the great legacy that the the roman empire it's it anyway it's still a great power leaves the byzantines is this incredible fortification system that um obviously the people of ninthth or 12th century Byzantium couldn't possibly have afforded but they have this incredible defensive system of walls that you can still go and see I mean if you know to walk around the walls of Constantinople is still one of the great things that you can do so that would be my nomination but if you've got a better one I'm not sure. That's a choice. So you mentioned Hadrian's Wall earlier on. We might as well get into Hadrian's Wall because I know you're itching to talk about it.
这就是罗马帝国——无论如何，它依然是一个伟大的政权——留给拜占庭人的伟大遗产，这个令人难以置信的防御系统。显然，9世纪或12世纪的拜占庭人根本无力负担这样的工程，但他们拥有这一不可思议的防御墙系统，你至今仍可以去参观。我的意思是，如果你懂的话，绕着君士坦丁堡的城墙走一圈依然是你可以体验到的最棒的事情之一。所以这就是我的提名。不过如果你有更好的，我不确定。这倒是个选择。所以你刚才提到了哈德良长城。我们不妨来聊聊哈德良长城，因为我知道你早就迫不及待想谈论它了。
And Hadrian's Wall is, I was there two years ago and I sort of went in that sort of cynical state of mind where you're expecting to be a little bit disappointed because I went as a child and hadn't been for 40 years or something and was expecting you know to be underwhelmed and it is an amazing thing isn't it hey dreams wall well it depends which bit of it you're looking at and i i say this with some feeling because um i've actually walked it three
至于哈德良长城，我两年前去过那里，当时我抱着一种挑剔的心态，觉得可能会有点失望，因为我小时候去过，已经有40年没去了，本来以为会大失所望。但它确实是个了不起的奇观，不是吗？哈德良长城？嗯，这取决于你在看它的哪一部分。我可是深有体会地说出这句话的，因为我实际上已经把整条长城徒步走过
times so i walked it when i was about 17 i walked it i was um when that just just after i got married i persuaded my beloved to walk with me. And that almost ended our marriage. Because we got lost. We got very badly lost. How did you get lost on Adrian's walk? It was before they'd set up a national path. So I misread a map. And anyway, fortunately, we're still together.
三次了。第一次是我大约17岁的时候，第二次是在我刚结婚后不久，我劝说我亲爱的妻子陪我一起走。那次差点导致我们的婚姻破裂。因为我们迷路了。我们迷路迷得很惨。你怎么会在哈德良长城迷路？那是他们设立国家步道之前的事了。所以我看错了地图。不管怎样，幸运的是，我们现在还在一起。
But it was quite close. And then about seven years ago, I made the whole family do it. And the children were quite young. And I showed them it was going to be exciting. And of course, we, you know, we set off from Wall's End and it just bucketed down with rain. You could never possibly have anticipated that, could you? No, I've got some very happy holiday snaps of the children sobbing in the outskirts of Newcastle as the gray rain slices down asking me why we couldn't have gone somewhere warmer but i agree it is hadrian's wall it is is fantastic and i
但当时真的差一点就散了。然后大约七年前，我带着全家人又走了一次。当时孩子们还很小。我向他们保证这会是一次刺激的旅行。当然，我们从“长城之端”（Wallsend）出发，结果迎面就是倾盆大雨。你永远也无法预料到会有这种天气，对吧？没有，我拍了一些非常开心的度假快照，照片里孩子们在纽卡斯尔的郊外嚎啕大哭，冰冷的雨水斜斜地下着，质问我为什么我们不能去一个更温暖的地方。但我同意，哈德良长城确实太棒了。我想
suppose i you see i think it i think for me it's the the archetype of the wall i was what i always think of and i think it's it's fascinating because it we don't entirely know why why it was built um so the only the only detail we have from from classical sources is it's written a source written about 250 years after the life of hadrian and it says the wall was built to separate the romans from the barbarians which is very kind of you know ambiguous so is it is it built as an expression of strength so you say you know we've we we control you perhaps they whitewashed it to make it stand out perhaps it was um kind of equivalent people had to present their passports to get through it's it's about making a massive statement of roman power or is it built as an expression of weakness in which case it's
你看，我觉得对我来说，它是墙的原型。我脑子里一直这么想。我觉得它很迷人，因为我们并不完全清楚它是为什么要建造的。所以我们从古典文献中得到的唯一细节是一份写于哈德良去世后大约250年的文献，上面说修筑长城是为了“将罗马人与野蛮人隔开”，这话非常耐人寻味、模棱两可。所以它到底是作为力量的表达而建造的？好让你宣称“我们控制了你们”——也许他们曾把它刷成白色以使其格外显眼？也许它相当于某种人们必须出示护照才能通过的关卡？这关乎发表宣示罗马权力的宏大声明；还是说它是作为软弱的表象而建造的？如果是这样，那它就是
about keeping the barbarians at bay and there's a kind of ambivalence there in the way that the walls are built you know that's true of the fortifications in china or wherever that's made even america that that is it is i do feel strong when you build it or are you projecting weakness but that's the ambiguity isn't it so that's the story of the great wall of china that you have to be a very rich and sophisticated society to build it, but you don't build it unless you're worried about steppe nomads, you know, raiding you and sort of pillaging all your towns and stuff. And presumably that's the case with Hadrian's Wall, right? That it's both, isn't it?
为了将野蛮人阻挡在外。这其中包含了一种矛盾心理，就像长城的建造方式一样——你知道的，中国的防御工事或是其他地方也是如此，甚至美国也是如此——建造它时你究竟是觉得自己很强大，还是在投射出虚弱？但这就是那种模棱两可之处，不是吗？所以这也是中国万里长城的故事：你必须是一个非常富有且成熟的社会才能建造它，但如果你不是担心草原游牧民族袭击你并洗劫你的所有城镇之类的话，你是不会去建造它的。想必哈德良长城也是如此，对吧？它两者兼而有之，不是吗？
That you have to be the Romans to build it, but equally, if you were so powerful, you'd have conquered what is now scotland yeah we see and what's interesting about the great wall of china is that the the the idea that it's um great is is basically a western one right interesting i mean you'll know this because it's nixon it's nixon i was thinking about nixon on the Wall. Because Nixon goes... He says famously, this is a great wall. It's a great wall for a great people or something. Yeah, that's his famous soundbite.
你必须是罗马人才能建造它，但同样地，如果你那么强大，你早就征服现在的苏格兰了。是的，你看，关于中国万里长城，有趣的是，它“伟大”这个概念基本上是一个西方概念，对吧？很有意思。嗯，你会知道这一点，因为是尼克松。我想到了尼克松在长城上的情景。因为尼克松去了……他有一句名言：这是一座伟大的长城。这是一座为伟大的人民而建的伟大的墙，或者类似的话。是的，那是他著名的金句。
There's a brilliant book, how do you... by Julia Lovell on the Great Wall. Yeah. And apparently that phrase got rewritten by Chinese propaganda. As he was meant to have said, it's a great wall for great people that come from a great past. And it's only a great people that built it. Again, have a great few. And these sort of endless greats kind of multiply.
有一本精彩绝伦的书，朱莉娅·洛夫（Julia Lovell）写的关于长城的书。是的。显然，这句话被中国的宣传口径重新改写了。按理说他说的是：这是一座为来自伟大过去的人民而建伟大的长城。只有伟大的人民才能建造它。再次强调，拥有一番伟大的视野。而这种无休止的“伟大”开始不断叠加。
But I mean, the Great Wall of China, you know, we think of it, it's basically a kind of showpiece. But that's because it's been renovated, hasn't it? So the bit that you go and see is actually just a very small bit but i mean ultimately there was no one great wall of china that has lasted for thousands and thousands of years and it seems to have kind of begun almost as a kind of gulag as a as a kind of you know the first emperor sending people off to to work themselves to death in the remotest corners of China. So that, again, is another kind of dimension of wall building, is that it's an expression of autocracy, an expression of power. And those who do it are, you know, it's built with their bones. Their bones are kind of ground up to become part of the mortar.
但我的意思是，中国的万里长城，我们通常认为它基本上算是一个门面。但这只是因为它经过了翻修，对吧？所以你去参观的那部分其实只是非常小的一部分。但归根结底，历史上并没有哪单一的一座伟大的中国长城历经数千年而不倒。它似乎几乎是从某种古拉格（劳改营）开始的——某种由第一位皇帝派遣百姓前往中国最偏远的角落劳累至死的苦役。所以这也是筑墙的另一个维度，即它是专制主义的表达，是权力的表达。而那些建造它的人，你知道的，这座墙是用他们的骨头建造的。他们的骨头被研磨开来，成为了砂浆的一部分。
Isn't that sort of true of all grand projet, you know, in is in history isn't it the pyramids and yeah you know the people it's not that sort of slightly tedious thing when you um when you're a child and you have a you know your parents have a friend who's a bit left wing like me and uh says who built the pyramids and you say oh ramesses or whoever it might be and he says no it was built by thousands of slaves and don't you forget it. I mean, that's a kind of standard. It wasn't slaves, was it? It was kind of Keynesianism.
这不正是所有宏大工程在历史上的真实写照吗，比如金字塔之类的？——那些人……当你还是个孩子的时候，如果你的父母有一个有点像我这样偏左的朋友，然后他说：“是谁建造了金字塔？”而你回答说：“哦，是拉美西斯或者别的什么人。”接着他说：“不，那是成千上万的奴隶建造的，你可别忘了。”——这种说法不觉得有点老套吗？我的意思是，那是一种标准的观点。那其实不是奴隶，对吧？那更像是凯恩斯主义。
It was giving everything something to do during the Fallot period. So let's talk a bit about not just walls but borders. Do you have a favourite border? Oh, come on, what is it? A favourite border? Oh, I think the sea that encloses great britain oh good choice good choice but you see we're on natural borders you see natural borders that's most borders aren't natural that's what's so interesting so there's a fantastic map online
那是为了在枯水期（或者说尼罗河泛滥期）给所有人找点事做。那么我们来聊聊不仅仅是墙，还有边境。你有什么最喜欢的边境吗？哦，得了吧，到底是什么？最喜欢的边境？哦，我想是环绕大不列颠的海。哦，不错的选择，不错的选择。但你看，我们谈论的是自然边境。你看，自然边境……大多数边境都不是自然的，这才是最有趣的地方。所以网上有一张精彩的地图，
that you can there's a website you can go to and there's a map and it tells you the dates of every major, well, not every major, every modern nation-state border. And by far the sort of plurality are 20th century. And actually when you go back, there are very few that are older than about 1300 or 1400. So I think one of the oldest is Spain and Portugal, which is 1297. Spain and France is very old, but most of the others are pretty new scotland and england scotland and england
你可以去一个网站，上面有一张地图，告诉你每一个主要的——嗯，不是每一个主要的，每一个现代民族国家边境的日期。其中绝大多数显然都是20世纪的。事实上，当你回溯历史时，很少有比公元1300年或1400年更早的边境。所以我想其中最古老的之一是西班牙和葡萄牙之间的边境，定于1297年。西班牙和法国的边境也非常古老，但大多数其他的边境都相当新。苏格兰和英格兰……苏格兰和英格兰
i mean kind of century and that but that's sort of shifted a bit hasn't it that's always been a little bit fluid um the scotland english well it's kind of interesting hadrian's wall stands in for the border between scotland and england where it's much it's further south interesting. Hadrian's Wall stands in for the border between Scotland and England. It's further south. And so there is this kind of idea that England is a natural inheritor of the Roman province of Britannia. And Scotland is a natural inheritor of the barbarian lands north of Hadrian's Wall. But that's not true at all. I mean, it's a kind of coincidence that the border tended to lie where it is yeah interesting what about the border between wales and england so that's kind of seen as the same as offers dyke isn't it people yeah that people use offers dyke as a kind of i don't know really i don't know anything about offer does anybody king of mercia well i think i mean i think with
我的意思是，大约是某个世纪……而且那也有所改变，不是吗？那条边境一直都有点流动性。苏格兰和英格兰的边境……有趣的是，哈德良长城可以代表苏格兰和英格兰之间的边境，尽管它位置更靠南。很有意思，哈德良长城可以替代苏格兰和英格兰的边境，但它更靠南。因此存在这样一种观点，即英格兰是罗马不列颠行省的自然继承者，而苏格兰则是哈德良长城以北蛮荒之地的自然继承者。但事实并非完全如此。我的意思是，边界恰好位于现今的位置这纯属一种巧合。是的，很有意思。那么威尔士和英格兰之间的边境呢？那通常被视为和奥发堤坝（Offa's Dyke）是一回事，对吧？人们……人们把奥发堤坝当作某种……我真的不知道，我对奥发一无所知。有谁知道麦西亚国王奥发吗？嗯，我想……我认为对于
office dyke again you get this kind of um the same ambivalence that you have with Adrian's Wall. Is it a statement of royal power? I mean, it is a statement of royal power, because for an Anglo-Saxon king to have the manpower to construct this enormous earthen dyke, I mean, that's pretty impressive by the standards of the time. But at the same time, it's kind of a mission of defeat that you can't bring the welsh to heal um and you've got to build this to stop them from raiding so again it's this same kind of uncertainty that you get with i suppose with you know in a way that's there with the berlin wall isn't it's there with north korea um yeah is it strength or is it weakness yeah if you're so great you don't need a great wall
奥发堤坝，你同样会看到这种……与哈德良长城一样的矛盾心理。这究竟是对王权的宣示吗？我的意思是，这确实是对王权的宣示，因为对于一个盎格鲁-撒克逊国王来说，要想拥有足够的人力来修建如此巨大的土堤，在当时的时代标准来看已经相当震撼了。但与此同时，这也是一种失败的承认——你无法让威尔士人屈服，
but also of course walls stand in for we've just been mentioning this wall stand in for natural borders so for rome you've got the rhine you've got the danube yeah um so they to a degree provide natural frontiers and i suppose the desert as well. I mean, the Roman Empire reaches its limit of natural expansion because southwards there's only the Sahara, eastwards there's only barbarians. You could go east into sort of Mesopotamia, couldn't you? I mean, the Romans didn't have to stop. Yeah.
而你不得不修建这个来阻止他们的袭扰。所以，这同样是你与哈德良长城所能感受到的那种不确定性——我想（某种程度上）这也存在于柏林墙、存在于朝鲜之中。是的，这究竟是力量还是软弱？是的，如果你真的那么强大，你根本不需要什么万里长城。
And was that border kind of fixed, the Roman-Persian border? I mean, it presumably was a little bit. That must have been very fluid. Yes, it is. Because in particularly late antiquity, there is no natural feature there. So essentially you have to construct massive frontier posts. And the story of the relationship between the Romans and the Persians in late antiquity is a constant process of scrapping over key
但当然，墙壁也往往代表着——我们刚刚提到过这一点——墙壁代表着自然边境。比如对罗马人来说，有莱茵河，有多瑙河。嗯……所以在一定程度上，它们提供了天然的边界。我想沙漠也是如此。我的意思是，罗马帝国的自然扩张达到了极限，因为向南只有撒哈拉沙漠，向东只有野蛮人。你可以向东进入美索不达米亚之类的地区，不是吗？我的意思是，罗马人本来不必停下脚步。是的。
nodes of defence which constitute the border. But I suppose what you have in modern history that you don't have in earlier periods is the sense of a solid definite border. I mean I think even Hadrian's Wall, Hadrian's Wall is not a line drawn in the sand because Roman power would be expected to project northwards. You know, troops would be expected to control frontiers northwards and also southwards as well. And the history of Roman defences is that to begin with, you have the idea that Roman power power is limitless that that empire is without borders this is the divine dispensation then you get the sense that you're going to kind of slightly build defenses along the line of the ryan and the daniel whatever then you have defense in depth and then you just give up because all things get swept away um so there are many different ways to have
那么那种边界——罗马与波斯之间的边界——算是固定的吗？我的意思是，它大概在一定程度上是固定的。那一定非常具有流动性。是的，确实如此。因为尤其是在晚期古典时代，那里没有天然的地标。所以基本上你必须构建大规模的边境哨所。而罗马人与波斯人在晚期古典时代的关系史，就是一个不断为了争夺构成边界的关键防御节点而进行厮杀的过程。但我想，现代历史中拥有而早期历史中所没有的，是一种坚实、明确的边界感。我的意思是，我认为即使是哈德良长城，哈德良长城也不是画在沙子上的线条，因为人们会期望罗马的权力向北延伸。你知道的，人们会期望军队去控制向北以及向南的边界。而罗马防御体系的历史是：一开始，你会认为罗马的权力是无限的，
borders and i suppose moving into um into the medieval period in the early modern period i mean borders constantly say poland but i mean talk me through the borders of poland i can't even begin to wrap my head around that no i mean poland is the famous one isn't it because even in the 20th century it changed multiple times um and you know what is poland now what we will accept to be poland would not have been accepted to be poland 1935 or 1900 when Poland didn't even exist on the map. So those things are interesting. I mean, people often say that the borders are a product of the Treaty of Westphalia. So that's 1648, the treaty that ends the 30 years war. And people see that some people see that as the moment that sort of enshrines the nation state. But if you go
帝国是没有边界的，这是神的恩赐；然后你会逐渐意识到，你大概需要在莱茵河、多瑙河或其他地方沿线修筑一点防御工事；再然后你开始进行纵深防御；接着你索性放弃，因为一切都被席卷而去了。所以拥有边境的方式有很多种，而我想进入中世纪和近代早期以后……我的意思是，波兰的边界一直在变。说吧，给我讲讲波兰的边界。我甚至都无法开始去理清头绪。不，我的意思是，波兰就是那个著名的例子，不是吗？因为甚至在20世纪，它也多次发生变化。而且，现在的波兰是什么？我们现在公认的波兰，在1935年或1900年波兰甚至都不在地图上存在的时候，是绝不会被承认是波兰的。所以这些事情很有意思。我的意思是，人们经常说边境是《威斯特伐利亚和约》的产物。那是1648年，结束了三十年战争的条约。人们认为——有些人认为那是确立民族国家地位的时刻。但如果你再往前追溯，
back even further, so if you go back to when Spain and Portugal were carving up the New World, I mean, they had to get a, they had a deal brokered by the Pope, the Treaty of Tordesillas and then the Treaty of Zaragoza, which basically said, you can have this bit, we'll have this bit.
比如回到西班牙和葡萄牙瓜分新世界的时候，我的意思是，他们不得不通过教皇斡旋达成一项协议，即《托德西利亚斯条约》，然后是《萨拉戈萨条约》，基本上规定了：“你可以拥有这部分，这部分归我们。”
There's such and such a parallel as the dividing line. So there was a sort of, I think once you've got maps, you've got borders. You know, once you can write it down and draw it then you've got a sense that this bit is ours it is inalienably part of our realm and that bit is yours but what i don't have any sense of and i've never really seen anybody explain it is what happened if you decided to get on your horse and to ride across you know central europe
以某某经纬线作为分界线。所以某种程度上，我认为一旦你有了地图，你就有了一成不变的边界。你知道的，一旦你能把它写下来并画出来，你就会有一种感觉：“这部分是我们的，它不可剥夺地属于我们的领土，而那部分是你的。”但我完全无法理解、也从来没见过任何人解释清楚的是：如果你决定骑上马，骑行穿过中欧或别的什么地方，
or whatever do you just keep going and nothing changes are they posts gates are you conscious of the language changing and all this sort of stuff i mean in the context of the broadest context of eurasia that is the huge issue isn't it that you've got horse horse riding nomads and then you've got everybody else or in the context of of the middle east you've got horse-riding nomads, and then you've got everybody else. Or in the context of the Middle East, you've got people on camels. Because actually, the very oldest wall, I think it's excavated by French archaeologists,
会发生什么？你会一直往前骑，却发现周围没有任何改变吗？那里有岗哨、大门吗？你会意识到语言发生了变化以及诸如此类的事情吗？我的意思是，在欧亚大陆最广阔的背景下，这是一个巨大的问题，对吧？那就是你拥有骑马的游牧民族，然后是其他所有人。或者在中东的背景下，你拥有骑骆驼的人。因为实际上，最古老的墙——我想是由法国考古学家发掘出来的，
and they just call it the Très Longue Mure. So the T-I-N. Good. They couldn't think of a better title than the Very Long Mure. It's brilliant. I brilliant it's about i think about 170 miles long it's in the desert of syria it's it's a kind of art and it's it's clearly there to keep the bedouin keep the the nomads out and it's the kind of precursor of all those other walls of which the defensive frontiers along the roman, the Rhine and the Danube, the Sasanian empires, the Persians,
他们干脆称之为“超长墙”（Très Longue Mure）。也就是 T-I-N。很好。他们想不出比“超长墙”更好的名字了。太妙了。这墙大概有170英里长，位于叙利亚的沙漠中，它是一道弧线，显然是为了把贝都因人、把游牧民族挡在外面。它是所有其他墙壁的先驱，其中就包括罗马沿着莱茵河和多瑙河的防御边界，萨珊王朝（波斯人）的边界——
they have one from the Black Sea to the Caspian Sea, China, of course, that there is this constant anxiety that if you build a great stable civilization and there are people out there on horses, you can come in and grab it, you've got a problem. The issue is there even with cities, isn't it? That the first cities, in a sense, have to... Walls have to be there, because otherwise people will just come and grab your stuff.
他们从黑海一直延伸到里海修筑了墙壁——当然还有中国。这就带来了一种持续的焦虑：如果你建立了一个伟大而稳定的文明，而外面有人骑着马随时可以进来抢夺你的东西，你就会遇到麻烦。这个问题甚至在城市建立之初就存在了，不是吗？最初的城市在某种程度上必须建有……墙必须存在，否则人们就会直接来抢你的东西。
Yeah. No, I think that's... Well, a wall is an intrinsic part of a city, isn't it? And a border is part of... I mean, this is, I think, one reason why people get so hot under the collar about... I mean, it's not obviously the only reason, but it's one reason why people get so hot under the collar about um i mean it's not the obviously the only reason but it's one reason why people get very hot under the collar about migration about the kind of migration stories in the newspapers is that a border is intrinsic to a nation state
是的。不，我认为这……好吧，墙是城市的一个内在组成部分，不是吗？而边界也是……我的意思是，我认为这就是为什么人们对……（当然这显然不是唯一的理由，但这确实是原因之一）为什么人们对移民问题感到如此激愤的一个原因——我的意思是，这当然不是唯一的理由，但这是人们对关于移民的新闻故事感到非常愤怒的一个原因：边界是民族国家的固有属性。
um it's a sort of nation state sense of its own inviolability um that you have a sort of well regulated border and that people can't sort of swornan in and out and that clearly is a is a motive for a lot of people i mean that's why trump got that success with the war and it's also i suppose i mean if you're thinking about emotive walls and borders think about ireland or northern ireland specifically so there you've got two different you've got the the irish northern irish border but you've also got the so-called peace walls in Belfast, which are walls to keep people apart, Catholics and Protestants. Have you done that tour in Belfast of all the sort? I haven't, no, I haven't, no.
嗯，这可以说是民族国家对其自身不可侵犯性的一种感知。你拥有一条管理良好的边界，人们不能随随便便地蜂拥进出。这显然是许多人的一个动机——我的意思是，这就是为什么特朗普凭借那堵墙取得了成功。而且我想，如果你在思考那些充满情绪化的墙壁和边界，可以想想爱尔兰，特别是北爱尔兰。在那里，你不仅有爱尔兰与北爱尔兰的边界，你还有贝尔法斯特所谓的“和平之墙”，这些墙是为了将不同的人群——天主教徒和新教徒——隔离开来。你去贝尔法斯特参观过所有那些……？没有，我没有去过。
I mean, it's extraordinary, you know, because, you know, in lots of ways, Belfast looks like, you know, you could be in a city in, people will probably be horrified by me saying this, but you could be in a city in Scotland or Northern England or something and you're driving along and then there's this massive wall this massive barrier that's keeping say the shankle road and the falls road apart and they would have gates well they still have gates which are sometimes locked at night so that people can't get in and out right well that's a i think a sombre note on which to end the first half.
我的意思是，这太不可思议了。因为在很多方面，贝尔法斯特看起来……你知道的，你可能会觉得身处……人们可能会对我接下来的话感到震惊，但你可能会觉得自己身处苏格兰或英格兰北部的一个城市，你开着车，然后突然出现了一堵巨大的墙，一堵巨大的屏障，将 Shankill 路和 Falls 路隔开。那里有大门——嗯，他们现在依然有大门，有时晚上会锁上，这样人们就无法随意进出。好吧，我认为这是一个以阴郁基调结束上半场的好时机。
We'll be back in the second half with some of your questions on walls and borders. I'm Marina Hyde. And I'm Richard Osman. And together we host The Rest Is Entertainment. It's your weekly fix of entertainment news, reviews, splash of showbiz gossip. And on our Q&A we pull back the curtain on entertainment and we tell you how it all works we have just launched our members club if you want ad-free listening bonus episodes and early access to live tickets head to the rest of the entertainment.com that's the rest is entertainment.com welcome back to the rest is History. A reminder that we've cranked up production
我们将在下半场回归，解答你们提出的一些关于墙壁和边界的问题。我是玛丽娜·海德（Marina Hyde）。我是理查德·奥斯曼（Richard Osman）。我们共同主持《娱乐余烬》（The Rest Is Entertainment）。这里有你每周必看的娱乐新闻、评论以及八卦爆料。在我们的问答环节中，我们将揭开娱乐业的神秘面纱，告诉你这一切是如何运作的。我们刚刚成立了会员俱乐部，如果你想收听无广告音频、独家加更节目并提前获得现场演出门票，请访问 therestisentertainment.com，也就是 therestisentertainment.com。欢迎回到《历史的余烬》。提醒一下，
while Britain remains in lockdown, two podcasts a week till February. So please do get in touch. We will always announce the subject of our next pod on Twitter. And we really do appreciate all your questions. Talking of which, we'll be coming to questions in a minute. But before we do, Dominic, you had a particular theme that you wanted to bring up.
趁着英国仍然处于封锁状态，我们加强了节目制作，从现在到2月每周推出两期播客。所以请务必与我们保持联系。我们总是会在推特上公布下一期播客的主题。我们真的非常感激你们提出的所有问题。说到这里，我们马上就会回答问题。但在那之前，多米尼克，你有一个特别的主题想要提出来。
Well, I thought of something that when we're talking about walls and borders, which is something we haven't addressed, which is enclaves. And they are so interesting. So one of the most famous ones is the city of Kaliningrad, which is a Russian enclave surrounded by basically what's now Poland, but what was east prussia and that's the city that was better known for most of history is koenigsberg city of emmanuel kant the the soviet union took it at the end of the second world war they didn't give it back they never will give it
好的，当我们在讨论墙壁和边界时，我想到了一个我们尚未探讨的事物，那就是飞地（Enclaves）。它们实在太有趣了。其中最著名的飞地之一就是加里宁格勒市，这是一个被基本上可以说是现今的波兰——但过去是东普鲁士——所包围的俄罗斯飞地。这座城市在历史上大部分时间里更为人所知的名字是柯尼斯堡（Koenigsberg），也就是哲学家伊曼纽尔·康德的城市。苏联在二战结束时占领了它，没有将其归还，也绝不会归还。
back the population is now russian and there's this sort of outpost of russianness now in what used to be a Prussian city in the middle of the European Union. An extraordinary thing. And of course, there are lots of enclaves all over the world. We just don't really know much about them. I suppose West Berlin was an enclave, wasn't it? West Berlin was an enclave, exactly.
如今那里的居民都是俄罗斯人。在曾经是一座普鲁士城市、如今却深处欧盟腹地的土地上，竟然存在着这样一个俄罗斯哨所。这是一件多么不可思议的事情。当然，世界各地还有许多飞地。我们只是对它们知之甚少。我想西柏林曾是一块飞地，对吧？西柏林正是一块飞地，完全正确。
So, I mean, how strange that was. West Berlin surrounded by a very hardcore, you know, communist East Germany for decades, apparently fixed. Yeah, I was tipped off about the peculiarities of the original border between India and what ended up as Bangladesh, which of course was drawn by Sir Cyril Radcliffe originally,
所以，这是多么奇特啊。西柏林几十年来一直被铁板一块、顽固的共产主义东德所包围，显然是固定的。是的，有人向我透露了印度与最终成为孟加拉国的地区之间最初边界的奇特性质。这条边界最初是由西里尔·拉德克利夫爵士（Sir Cyril Radcliffe）划定的，
who also did the border between what becomes India and Pakistan. And it turns out there were loads of enclaves there that I think only got sorted out between Bangladesh and India kind of like 20, 30 years ago. But this actually goes to the point that we were talking about earlier about borders, that most borders are quite recent because they've been constructed in the wake of the disintegration of empires. So when people were drawing borders, even in Western Europe,
他同时也是划定印度与巴基斯坦边界的人。事实证明，那里有大量的飞地，我记得这些飞地大约是在20, 30年前才在孟加拉国和印度之间得到解决的。但这实际上印证了我们之前讨论的关于边界的观点：大多数边界都相当新近，因为它们是在帝国解体之后构建起来的。因此，当人们在划定边界时，甚至在西欧，
so Austria's borders, for example, they had to have plebiscites at the end of the Austro-Hungarian empire to decide would Carinthia be Austrian or would it be Yugoslav. So there's always this sort of arbitrariness. You have to have enclaves if you're not going to force people to live in, as it were, the wrong country. And I don't know which is, I mean, probably enclaves are better, but you've just had a war in Armenia and Azerbaijan about the enclaves, about Nagorno-Karabakh and all that.
例如奥地利的边界，在奥匈帝国结束时，他们不得不通过公民投票来决定克恩顿州究竟是归属奥地利还是南斯拉夫。所以其中总是存在某种任意性。如果你不想强迫人们生活在“错误的国家”，你就必须设立飞地。我不知道哪种更好——大概飞地更好一些，但你们刚刚在亚美尼亚和阿塞拜疆之间经历了一场关于飞地的战争，关于纳戈尔诺-卡拉巴赫以及诸如此类的事。
I mean, one of the issues, I suppose, particularly in areas of the world that haven't had the inheritance of the Treaty of Westphalia, haven't got great accustomed to it, is that actually empires are far more kind of representative of how power has been organised. And one of the advantages, I suppose,
我想，其中的一个问题——特别是在那些没有继承《威斯特伐利亚和约》传统的地区，对它没有习惯——在于，帝国实际上远更能代表权力的组织方式。而帝国的优势之一，我想，
of empires is that you can have enclaves because you're all part of the same imperial structure. And essentially, in the Middle East, empires have been the natural way of things going right the way back to the time of Sargon of Akkad. Yeah, or the Balkans. I mean, the Balkans were Roman, they were Byzantine,
就在于你可以拥有飞地，因为你们都是同一个帝国结构的一部分。从本质上讲，在中东，帝国一直是事物运转的自然方式，一直可以追溯到阿卡德的萨尔贡时期。是的，或者巴尔干地区。我的意思是，巴尔干地区曾属于罗马，属于拜占庭，
they were Ottoman orantine they were ottoman they or austro-hungarian then that all fell apart and then you know people just started fighting about where they start and end but it's it's also isn't it um it's it's to do with the rise of technology as well and mapping as you mentioned before and essentially the ability to the to have accurate maps to draw lines on them and then to ensure that those lines are upheld so moving on to the question seamlessly we have one from um paradoximoron that's an excellent name that's a great name and he remembers during my master's i had to write an essay on the hardening of the world's borders it turns out that most of the world's borders have become more heavily guarded since the end of the Cold War.
曾属于奥斯曼帝国，然后属于奥匈帝国，接着这一切分崩离析，然后（你知道的）人们又开始为彼此的起点和终点争斗不休。但这也是……难道不是吗？——这其实也与技术的兴起以及正如你之前提到的地图测绘有关。从本质上讲，就是拥有精确的地图、在上面划定线条，并确保这些线条得到维护的能力。所以，顺理成章地转到下一个问题，我们收到了一个来自“悖论莫龙”（paradoximoron）的提问——这是一个极好的名字，真是个好名字。他回忆说：在我读硕士期间，我必须写一篇关于“世界边界硬化”的论文。事实证明，自冷战结束以来，世界上大多数边界受到的武装看守反而变得更加严密了。
What do you think explains this? Well, this is a question for you, Dominic. But one thing that just hovers on my mind, have you been watching The Serpent? No, the Jenna Coleman serial killing thing. Yes. Charles Sobhraj, who was a serial killer of backpackers in in the 70s um and the absolute tension about that revolves around the fact that um there's no internet there are no mobile phones that he can take backpackers passports and then they've got no way of getting out um and you can kind of you can you can take photographs out of a passport and put another photo in and just use it as your own.
你认为是什么解释了这一点？好吧，这个问题得抛给你，多米尼克。但有一件事一直萦绕在我的脑海里：你看过《蛇蝎美少年》（The Serpent）吗？没有。就是詹娜·科尔曼（Jenna Coleman）演的那个连环杀人案的剧集。查尔斯·索布拉吉（Charles Sobhraj），他是70年代专门针对背包客的连环杀手。而那部剧里绝对的紧张感正是围绕着这样一点展开：当时没有互联网，没有手机，他可以拿走背包客的护照，然后他们就没有任何办法逃脱。
And you realize how, you know, in 40 years, how 50 years, how radically technology has has hardened the ability of states to monitor who comes in and out of their countries. I've got a terrifying passport border story for you, Tom. I once got an overnight train from Estonia to Russia. And as we were pulling into St. Petersburg, I realised that my passport had disappeared and I couldn't find it anywhere. That's not a good point. It's terrible.
你可以……你可以把护照上的一张照片揭下来，贴上另一张照片，然后直接把它当成你自己的护照来使用。这让你意识到，在短短40年、50年里，技术极大地强化了国家监控其境内外人员进出的能力。汤姆，我有一个关于护照边境的吓人故事要讲给你听。我曾经坐过一趟从爱沙尼亚开往俄罗斯的夜行列车。当列车缓缓驶入圣彼得堡时，我突然意识到我的护照不见了，而且我怎么也找不到它。那可不是什么好兆头。太可怕了。
You're an undocumented alien entering Vladimir Putin's Russia. What year was this? It was about 2002 2003 but they were in the middle of a huge panic because a lot of bombs were going off in russia they're in the second chechen war as i remember and and dominic be honest he looked like a chechen terrorist exactly exactly and uh you know where it was so basically the sort of the the the woman who took care of our sleeper carriage had come in and done all the laundry. She was desperate to get all this sort of laundry,
你成了一个非法入境弗拉基米尔·普京的俄罗斯的无证人员。这是哪一年？大约是2002年或2003年。但他们当时正处于极度恐慌之中，因为俄罗斯发生了很多炸弹袭击。我记得当时他们正处于第二次车臣战争期间。多米尼克，说实话，你当时看起来就像一个车臣恐怖分子。完全是，完全是。你知道它在哪吗？基本上……照看我们卧铺车厢的那个女乘务员进来把所有的床单都收走了。她急于把所有这些换洗床单、
get all the bed sheets off and everything. And she'd whipped up my passport and it was at the bottom of this massive laundry bag. So you managed to find it? I did. I made a huge scene. Oh, you must have been... It was that English thing of, I thought, is it worse to make a scene
把所有的床单什么的都收理干净。她把我的护照顺手卷了进去，结果它就掉在这个巨大洗衣袋的最底部。所以你最后找到了？找到了。我当时大闹了一场。哦，你当时一定……那种英国式的拘谨感油然而生：我在想，到底是当众大闹一场、在所有其他乘客面前丢脸更糟糕呢，还是直接在俄罗斯监狱里度过十年更糟糕？我能看出这确实很难权衡。
and embarrass myself in front of all the other passengers, or should I just take the ten years in the Russian prison? I can see that's a difficult one to weigh up. In which I can console myself. At least I showed a stiff upper lip. I hope you took the ten years in prison. No, I didn't. Well, I didn't, clearly.
在这个过程中，我还可以自我安慰：至少我表现出了坚忍不拔的硬汉作风。我希望你当时选了在监狱里蹲十年。不，我没有选。好吧，显然我没选。你当时哭了吗？双腿发软、嚎啕大哭？不管怎样，我们实际上根本没有回答“悖论莫龙”的问题。所以我对他的问题的回答很简单：移民。移民人数大幅增加，随之而来的是边界管控的加强。随着移民潮的涌现，你不觉得是这样吗？是的，但你不觉得边界之所以变得更加严密，是因为人们有能力把它们变严密吗？对，我想是的。
Did you cry? Fall on your knees and sob? Anyway, we actually haven't answered Paradoxly Morons' question at all. So my answer to his question is as simple as migration. Migration has hugely increased and, you know, borders controls have increased with them. With migrant flows, don't you think? Yeah, but don't you think that the borders have hardened because people can harden them? Yes, I suppose so.
（重复）……但你不觉得边界之所以变得更加严密，是因为人们有能力把它们变严密吗？对，我想是的。你知道的，所以现在你去美国之类的国家时，必须留下指纹，他们会给你拍无数张照片，还要经历一整套那样的折腾，我猜他们以前可不会这样。你以前只需要一张纸和一个隔着柜台怒视着你的男人。是的。你知道的，现在如果没有合适的文件，你哪儿也去不了，然而……没错。
You know, so now you have to give a fingerprint when you think that the borders have hardened because people can harden them? Yes, I suppose so. You know, so now you have to give a fingerprint when you go into the United States or whatever and they take endless photos of you and all that sort of carry on, which I guess they didn't before. You just had a piece of paper and a man glaring at you across the desk. Yeah. You know, you can't go anywhere without the right papers now, whereas... No. That's because we're so sensitive about migration, isn't it? I mean, that wasn't the case in 1992 or something when, you know, the phrase asylum seekers was barely used in the news and immigration into most European countries was pretty low.
那是因为我们对移民问题太敏感了，不是吗？我的意思是，在1992年左右可不是这样的，当时“寻求庇护者”（asylum seekers）这个词在新闻中几乎不怎么使用，而且大多数欧洲国家的移民率都相当低。你不觉得这是对这种焦虑产生的一种产物吗？是的，我想是的。我想是的，没错。但我认为这也关乎……如果你拥有的技术足以让你去做某件事，那么你就会去做。
Don't you think it's a product of the anxiety about that? Yeah, I suppose so. I suppose so, yeah. But I think it's also about you know if the technology is there to uh enable you to do stuff then then you do it um which brings us very neatly on to another question from um amy matravadi who asked perhaps a discussion of the great firewall of china so this is the future isn't it i suppose yeah so this is the that's a good question so it's I suppose? Yeah. So this is the... That's a good question. So now the issue is not you're keeping people out or in, because that's keeping people out of China is not really something that I imagine the Chinese are
这就非常巧妙地引出了来自艾米·马特拉瓦迪（Amy Matravadi）的另一个问题：或许我们可以讨论一下中国的“防火长城”（Great Firewall）。所以这才是未来，对吧？我想是的。所以这就是……这是一个好问题。所以这……我想是的。所以这就是……这是一个好问题。现在的问题不再是把人挡在外面或关在里面，因为把人挡在国门之外并不是中国人在真正担心的事情。
terribly worried about. It's more about keeping ideas out. So am I not right in thinking that there's some issue with Winnie the Pooh in China? Are you aware of this? That's right. Yes, yes. Xi Jinping looking like Winnie the Pooh in the Disney film. And so Winnie the Pooh has been suppressed. He's a non-bear. He's a non-bear. This is going to get a podcast suppressed in China. Oh, my God.
这更多的是关于把思想和观念挡在外面。所以，我没记错的话，中国关于“小熊维尼”（Winnie the Pooh）是不是有什么争议？你知道这件事吗？没错，是的，是的。因为习近平看起来像迪士尼电影里的小熊维尼。于是小熊维尼就被封禁了。他变成了一只“非熊”。他变成了一只“非熊”。这会让我们的播客在中国也被封禁的。噢，天哪。
But, yeah, how effective is this? I don't know. I mean, only time will tell how well it's working. Clearly, it doesn't work with Lutheran ideas in the 16th century. It doesn't work with Enlightenment ideas or communism. You can't keep ideas out, I don't think. is kind of interesting because, you know, you're saying how the idea of the Great Wall of China is essentially a European invention. Europeans start going there and having, you know, rhapsodising about this amazing wall, and then the Chinese wake up to the fact that they've got this incredible thing, and you start getting all these stories about how it's the only structure that you can see from the moon, perhaps even from Mars,
但是，是的，这到底有多大效果？我不知道。我的意思是，只有时间才能证明它到底管不管用。显然，它对16世纪的路德教思想没用。它对启蒙运动思想或共产主义也没用。我认为，你根本阻挡不了思想的传播。这其实挺有趣的，因为，你知道的，你刚才提到中国长城这个概念本质上其实是一个欧洲的发明。欧洲人开始去那里，并且对这堵令人惊叹的墙赞不绝口，然后中国人才突然意识到他们竟然有这么个了不起的东西，接着就开始流传各种传说，说它是唯一一个从月球上甚至可能是从火星上都能看到的建筑，
I think Joseph needham said um and so the chinese become end up very proud of it and it becomes an emblem of their ability to protect their civilization yeah from the barbarians that that lie out there now whether that was the original purpose of of these kind of various fortifications that collectively have come to be called the Great Wall of China, I don't know. But I think that the idea that China is the great centre of civilisation, it's the Middle Kingdom, and you put a wall around it to keep the barbarians out, that is something that goes with the grain of Chinese national pride as it's evolved over the past century, really.
我想约瑟夫·李约瑟说过嗯，所以中国人们最终对此感到非常自豪，它成了他们保护自己文明能力的象征，是的，抵御那些潜伏在外的蛮族。现在，这究竟是不是这些各种各样统称为中国长城的防御工事最初的目的，我不知道。但我认为，中国是文明的伟大中心，它是中原之国，你建一堵墙把它围起来把蛮族挡在外面，这种想法确实与过去一个世纪演变而来的中国民族自豪感的核心不谋而合。
So maybe that's a part of it. I think it is. And I think actually you're right in that if you talk to Chinese people about it, they don't say, well, this is a sign of weakness and of our insecurity. They see it, as you say, I think they see it as a sign of this is who we are.
所以也许这就是其中的一部分。我想是的。而且我觉得你其实说得对，如果你跟中国人们谈起这个，他们不会说，哦，这标志着我们的软弱和不安全感。正如你所说，他们认为，我认为他们将其视为一种宣示：这就是我们是谁。
We control what comes in and out. It's a sign of our maturity and that we're sensible, that we don't let the internet become this anarchic free-for-all that you have in the West, that we want to have a sense of regulation. And maybe they've got a point. Well, maybe. I mean, who knows? I mean, we're speaking just a couple of days after Donald course and maybe they've got a point well maybe i mean who knows i mean we're speaking this is a couple of days after donald trump's been kicked off twitter no one in china is on twitter are they they've they've kind of banned it they've got their own
我们掌控着什么东西能进来，什么东西能出去。这是我们成熟和明智的象征，表明我们不会让互联网变成西方那种无法无天的自由市场，我们希望有一种监管意识。也许他们说得有道理。好吧，也许吧。谁知道呢？我的意思是，我们录音的时候正值唐纳德……好吧，也许他们说得有道理，好吧，也许吧，谁知道呢？我的意思是，我们录音的时候正值唐纳德·特朗普被赶出推特几天后，中国没有人用推特，对吧？他们差不多把它给禁了，他们有他们自己的
they have their own parallel things don't they yeah i guess yeah um yeah they famous in notoriety they haven't got rid of um president of iran so he's still no he's still on twitter yeah he's still on twitter tweeting um well here's here's another modern war from um i hope i'm going to pronounce this right um pepin luka um the israeli war separating israelis from the palestinians how successful is it oh yeah thank you for asking me this very uncontentious question. Well, I suppose you can argue it's ultimately successful only up to a point. I don't really know, and I've never been to Israel or indeed Palestine, so I don't really know.
他们有他们自己的类似平台，对吧？是的，我想是的，嗯，是的，它们臭名昭著，他们没有摆脱嗯伊朗总统，所以他仍然没有，他仍然在推特上，是的，他仍然在推特上发推文，嗯，这里是来自嗯的另一个现代战争，希望我把这个名字念对了，嗯，佩平·卢卡，以色列人与巴勒斯坦人隔离的隔离墙，这有多成功？哦，是的，谢谢你问我这个一点也不具争议的问题。嗯，我想你可以说它最终的成功也只是相对而言的。我其实并不知道，而且我也从未去过以色列或巴勒斯坦，所以我真的不知道。
I don't have any first-hand experience of which to draw. But, I mean, the thing with the wall is you can build a wall, but the other people are still there, right? And the issue is still there. It doesn't go away. So, I mean, an Israeli, you you know if you had an israeli spokesman they would say well it's improved improved security or whatever but of course the the problem the point i suppose for the israelis is at what point does that wall become a greater problem because of the
我没有任何第一手经验可以借鉴。但是，我的意思是，关于墙的问题在于，你可以修一堵墙，但其他人依然在那里，对吧？问题依然存在，它并没有消失。所以，我的意思是，一个以色列人，你知道的，如果你有一个以色列发言人，他们会说这改善了安全状况或者别的什么，但当然，对于以色列人来说，问题的关键在于，在哪个点上，由于以下原因，这堵墙会变成一个更大的问题
international pr damage you know what point does it harm your cause rather than help it? I don't have an answer to that. I mean, again, as in China, so in the Near East, there's a lot of history there. So one of the towns in Palestinian territories is Jericho, which possibly has some of the most famous walls in the whole of history um and you know all over the near east you've got these kind of what are called tells so dust mounds that
国际公关损害，你知道，在哪个点上它会损害你的事业而不是帮助它？我没有答案。我的意思是，正如在中国一样，在中东也是如此，那里有着悠久的历史。因此，巴勒斯坦领土上的城镇之一是杰里科，它可能拥有整个历史上最著名的一些城墙，嗯，你知道的，在整个近东地区，你都有这种被称为“特尔”的东西，也就是尘土堆，
were once cities and uh you know we've got um the uh the very long wall as well out in out in syria so you do i mean perhaps of more than anywhere else in the world, in that area of the world, walls have an incredibly long history. And I suppose that, you know, the Israelis live in the shadow of that kind of incredibly ancient history. Oh, well, OK, so here's the next one from Ollie O'Brien. And this is something we've already touched on. When did borders become an actual thing?
曾经是城市，嗯，你知道的，我们还有嗯，叙利亚境内的那道很长的墙，所以确实，我的意思是，也许比世界上任何其他地方都要多，在世界的那片土地上，城墙有着极其悠久的历史。我想，你知道的，以色列人就生活在那种极其古老的历史阴影之下。哦，好吧，好的，所以这里是奥利·奥布莱恩提出的下一个问题。这也是我们之前已经触及过的话题。边界究竟是什么时候成为现实存在的？
1648 and the Treaty of Westphalia? Or not until faster transport and more people travelling by train? An example being German unification, I suppose. I mean, I think we've been kind of hovering around that question, really. When you have borders. Our borders, as we understand them now definite lines with border posts um you know satellite absolutely determine where exactly these borders are when did we start getting the idea that they are definite lines on a map rather than just kind of vague areas
1648年的《威斯特伐利亚和约》？还是直到更快的交通工具出现、更多人乘火车出行之后？我想，德国统一就是一个例子。我的意思是，我觉得我们其实一直在围绕这个问题打转。什么时候才有了边界。我们现在所理解的边界——带有边防哨所的明确界限，嗯，你知道的，用卫星绝对确定这些边界究竟在哪里——我们是从什么时候开始有这种概念的：它们是地图上的明确界限，而不仅仅是某种模糊的区域？
control kind of frontier regions i don't actually have an answer to that, Tom. I think it's interesting he mentions train, because obviously trains, some people argue trains invented time. So train timetables invent a kind of national uniformity of clocks. Every station has to have the same time and all the rest of it. At what point, I mean, this is the thing that puzzles me, actually, that genuinely puzzles me. At what point are you on your this is the thing that puzzles me, actually, that genuinely puzzles me. At what point are you on your horse and you're in France,
控制某种边境地区。汤姆，我其实没有答案。我觉得他提到火车很有意思，因为显然火车，有人说火车发明了时间。所以火车时刻表发明了一种时钟的国家统一性。每个车站都必须有相同的时间，诸如此类。在哪个点上，我的意思是，这是真正让我感到困惑的事情，真的让我感到困惑的事情。在哪个点上，你骑着马，你身在法国，
then you're in Luxembourg, then you're in, you know, one of the states of what becomes Germany? How conscious are you of it? Is there somebody stopping you? And at what point is there somebody stopping you? My guess is we're talking 19th century. But I don't know. And when people did the grand tour they didn't need to take loads of documents with them and they didn't have to stop and have their bags searched i suppose travel was so expensive that if you were traveling you were
然后你在卢森堡，然后你在，你知道的，后来成为德国的某个邦？你对这一切有多大意识？有没有人在半路拦住你？在哪个点上会有人拦住你？我猜我们说的是19世纪。但我不知道。而且当人们进行壮游（Grand Tour）时，他们不需要随身携带大量文件，也不必停下来接受行李检查，我想当时的旅行是如此昂贵，以至于如果你在旅行，你
automatically assumed to be a a mill lord and that meant money so everyone would welcome you with open arms happy days when british tourists were still welcome on the continent. But one day... We're left with bags of marble. Coming from a very different angle is that perhaps one of the things that constitutes a border, say in antiquity, is the idea that the land is sacred. So in Athens, in Attica, I mean, Athens is unusual in ancient Greece because it controls such a large
自动被认为是一个领主，这意味着有钱，所以每个人都会张开双臂欢迎你。当英国游客在欧洲大陆还受到欢迎时，真是美好的日子。但总有一天……我们只剩下满袋的大理石。从一个非常不同的角度来看，也许在古代，构成边界的事情之一是土地是神圣的这一观念。因此在雅典，在阿提卡，我的意思是，雅典在古希腊是不寻常的，因为它控制着如此广袤的
quantity of territory. And that territory is seen as being sacred. So the Athenians see themselves as being autochthonous, born from the soil. And you have to be buried in Athenian soil. And unless if you are born from Athenian soil, then you are Athenian. There's no other way you can become an Athenian. So I suppose if you have a sense that the earth itself is sacred, I suppose, again, that's part of Israel as well, the idea of a promised land, a holy land. With the Romans, you have a thing called the pomerium, which is a sacred border that marks the sacral limits of the city um so if you have a sense that land is sacred then i suppose inevitably you probably have a sense of borders as well but i'm not sure about that something to something to i mean there's sort of the sort of trendy thing to say right is that borders are always fluid and they're terribly interesting and they're much more
领土。而且这片领土被认为是神圣的。因此，雅典人认为自己是本土诞生的，从泥土中生出。你必须被埋葬在雅典的泥土中。除非你是从雅典的泥土中诞生，否则你就是雅典人。没有其他方式可以让你成为一个雅典人。所以我想，如果你有一种大地本身是神圣的观念，我想，这也适用于以色列，即对应许之地、圣地的观念。对于罗马人来说，你们有一个叫做“波麦里姆”（pomerium）的东西，它是一个标志着城市神圣界限的神圣边界，嗯，所以如果你觉得土地是神圣的，那么我想不可避免地你可能也会有边界的观念，但我对此并不确定。这只是一些……我的意思是，现在有一种比较时髦的说法是，边界永远是流动的，它们非常有趣，而且比非边界有趣得多，诸如此类。但边界并非总是那么流动——我之前提到过西班牙和葡萄牙，我的意思是，那个边界在过去的800年里几乎一直保持在原地，而这期间两侧的人民对自身都有着非常清晰的意识：我们是葡萄牙人，你是西班牙人。我的意思是，其中一定存在某种程度的流动性。
interesting than non-borders and all the rest of it but borders aren't always that fluid so i mentioned spain and portugal earlier i mean that border has remained pretty much where it is than non-borders and all the rest of it. But borders aren't always that fluid. So I mentioned Spain and Portugal earlier. I mean, that border has remained pretty much where it is for I think 800 years. And the people on either side in all that time have had a pretty clear sense of themselves. We're Portuguese, you're Spanish. I mean, there must have been a degree of fluidity.
但他们不认为自己是西班牙人，对吧？因为在这个边界之内，存在着各种各样的其他东西。但他们不认为自己是西班牙人，对吧？因为在这个边界之内，存在着各种各样的其他边界。比如将要成为安达卢西亚的地方与瓦伦西亚、卡斯蒂利亚之间的边界，以及所有这些边界。我的意思是，那是在不断转变和变化的。所以也许你有……
But they don't think they're Spanish, do they? Because within that border, there are all kinds of otherity. But they don't think they're Spanish, do they? Because within that border, there are all kinds of other borders. So the borders between what's going to become Al-Andalus and then Valencia and Castile and all these. I mean, that's kind of shifting and changing. So perhaps you have...
是的。还有南美洲的边界，对吧？南美洲的边界往往遵循西班牙帝国内部的模式。也就是行政区划，你知道的，为什么会有阿根廷、智利、乌拉圭和所有这些地方？它们往往遵循西班牙帝国的行政区划。事实上，玻利瓦尔在他们那个伟大的独立战争时代，曾梦想过一个大哥伦比亚，这个巨大的超级国家。它失败了，因为各自的精英们想要死死抓住他们的边界不放。
Yeah. And the borders in South America, right? The borders in South America follow often the patterns within the Spanish Empire. So the administrative divisions, you know, why is there Argentina and Chile and Uruguay and all these places? Often they follow the administrative divisions of the Spanish Empire. And actually Bolivar, when they, you know, in the great age of sort of independence fighting, he dreamed of a Gran Colombia, this big super state. And it failed because the individual elites wanted to cling on to their borders.
他们想要自己的小权力基地。还有英国人也是。我的意思是，几乎在世界各地，无论哪里有特别可怕的冲突热点，结果往往都是由英国制图师造成的。是的。你知道的，从北爱尔兰到以色列。可怕的冲突热点，结果往往都是由英国制图师造成的。是的，你知道的，从北爱尔兰到……尽管汤姆，我总是纳闷，我总是觉得这是一种绝妙的推卸责任的方式，不是吗？对几代之后的人来说，哦，那是那些邪恶之人的错，而实际上我真的需要去屠杀我的邻居，这完全不是我的错。好吧，但我猜英国人和西班牙人和法国人来自一个将边界观念视为理所当然的大陆，然后去到世界各地，在那里
They wanted their little power bases. And the British as well. I mean, almost across the globe, wherever there's some particularly terrifying flashpoint, it turns out that a British mapmaker. Yes. You know, from Northern Ireland through Israel. terrifying flashpoint it turns out that a british map maker yes you know from northern ireland through although tom i always wonder i always i always think this is a great cop-out isn't it for people generations later to say oh it's the fault of those evil and actually i i really need to go and massacre my neighbors and it's not my fault at all well i but i suppose the british and spanish are coming from a continent in which the idea these idea of borders is taken for granted and going to parts of the world where
这些观念在某种程度上是相当陌生的，嗯，因为西方力量在20世纪占据了压倒性优势，是的，这种观念被视为理所当然，并且隐含在联合国等机构中，但实际上，它是西方力量衰落中的一个时代的表现。所以我不知道威斯特伐利亚式的边界概念是否也会消散。这是一个很好的观点。我想，实际上还有一点。有一点。也许我们英国人对边界太随意了，正是因为我们没有边界。
they're they're kind of rather alien ideas and um because western power was so preponderant over the 20th century yeah this idea was kind of taken for granted and is implicit in the united nations and things but it's actually it's expressive of an age of an age of Western power that is in retreat now. So I don't know whether the notion of a kind of Westphalian border will fade as well. That's a good point. And I guess, actually, one other point. There is a point. Maybe we British are too cavalier about borders precisely because we don't have one.
还没有。我们可能会有。如果苏格兰独立公投走向我认为错误的方向——但也不一定。这是一个属于苏格兰人的问题。好吧，这里有另一个问题。同样，我希望我把这个名字念对了，蒂姆·谢普洛夫斯基（Tim Cieplowski）。
Yet. We may. If the Scottish independence vote goes what I would think would be the wrong way, but not necessarily. One for the Scottish. OK, here's another question. Again, I hope I pronounce this right. Tim Cieplowski.
谢普洛夫斯基。谢普洛夫斯基。最后一个还在运作的带城墙的城市是什么，它们还会卷土重来吗？我不知道，你知道吗？嗯，所以还有很多带城墙的城市仍在运作，但我的意思是人们不会去围攻它们，我想这就是它所寻找的吗？嗯……因为你怎么……嗯，也许是一个城墙是其运作的重要组成部分的城市。人们不被允许进出。
Cieplowski. Cieplowski. What was the last functioning walled city and will they ever make a comeback i don't know that do you um so there are lots of walled cities still which function but i mean people don't besiege them i suppose that is that what it's looking for um uh because how do you well maybe it may be a city where the wall is is is an important part of its functioning. People aren't allowed in or out.
我的意思是，有带城墙的城市，对吧？最好的带城墙的城市，我告诉你……梵蒂冈或许可以算一个，我想。梵蒂冈有一道墙，对吧？所以那标示出了它的界限。我告诉你，你去过……你一定去过杜布罗夫尼克，汤姆。那是一个非常……
I mean, there are walled cities, aren't there? The best walled city, I tell you... The Vatican, perhaps, might be one, I suppose. The Vatican has a wall, doesn't it? So that marks out the limits. I tell you, have you been to... You must have been to Dubrovnik, Tom. That's a very...
不，我从未去过杜布罗夫尼克。你从来没去过？没有。所以城墙是杜布罗夫尼克的一个巨大要素。所以杜布罗夫尼克是……国王已降。没有。所以城墙是杜布罗夫尼克的一个巨大要素。所以杜布罗夫尼克是《权力的游戏》中的君临城。而城墙是杜布罗夫尼克魅力的巨大要素。
No, I've never been to Dubrovnik. You've never been? No. So the wall is a huge element of Dubrovnik's. So Dubrovnik is King been. No. So the wall is a huge element of Dubrovnik's. So Dubrovnik is King's Landing from Game of Thrones. And the wall is a huge element of Dubrovnik's appeal.
而且城墙实际上既成就了杜布罗夫尼克，也毁了它。从某种意义上说，它是人们前往那里的原因，而正因为人们前往那里，它变成了一种迪士尼化的度假胜地，挤满了巨型游轮，这剥夺了它的特色，但就带城墙的城市而言，我的意思是那是你去过的最好的带城墙的城市
And the wall has actually both made and destroyed Dubrovnik in the sense that it's the reason people go and because people go, it has become a sort of Disney-fied resort with colossal cruise ships which has leached it of its of its character but in terms of walled cities i mean that is the best walled city you'll ever go to
好吧，好吧，它绝对在我的愿望清单上，你知道的，我梦想着能去看看它的那一天，但我对“最后一个还在运作的带城墙的城市”这个问题的回答会是梵蒂冈。所以，好吧，但我可能猜错了，因为我不是带城墙城市的专家，所以如果有听众有更好的建议，我们很乐意听取。不过我接下来要给你抛出阿杰·布雷姆纳（AJ Bremner）提出的另一个问题：城墙只有在有人把守时才是一堵成功的城墙吗？好问题，啊哈，是的，我想……好吧，如果你不守卫一堵墙，它的意义何在？我的意思是，关于哈德良长城上究竟有没有一条步行道，哈德良长城学者之间有一场有趣的辩论，我的意思是你会认为长城上肯定有，是的，是的，所以士兵们可以沿着长城走来走去
okay well it's i it's absolutely on my list and you know dreaming of time where i can go and see it but i would my answer to that last functioning walled city would be the vatican so okay but i may have got that wrong because i'm not an expert in walled city so if you if anyone out there has a better suggestion we'd love to hear from you but i was going to give you another question from aj bremner is a wall only a successful wall if it's guarded good question uh huh yes i suppose it well if you're not guarding a wall what's the point of it i mean there's there's an there's an interesting debate among hadrian's wallologists about whether there was a walkway on the wall i mean you'd assume that there there were on the wall yeah yeah so you know the soldiers can walk up and down the wall
是的，这是一个引发巨大争论的话题，你知道的，考古学家们为此争执不下，那么一定有成千上万的书籍完全是错误和多余的，哪些士兵在长城上瞭望？我的意思是，是的，是的，当然，我的意思是，我一定读过上千篇文章，里面提到非洲士兵在长城上瞭望，这是一种……好吧，他们在堡垒里，所以显然他们起到了某种防御作用，但长城被视为更像是一种，你知道的，海关标志或者，是的，我们之前说过，是权力的表现什么的，是的，它不是一个实际用于抵御……是的，抵御蛮族的平台。所以借用你的《权力的游戏》类比，它不是那种野人将自己抛向长城并被……击退的场景，有什么证据表明这一点吗？有人袭击过长城吗？哈德良
yeah there's it's a topic of massive debate you know archaeologists fall out about this then there must be thousands of books that are utterly erroneous and redundant which soldiers are looking out from the wall i mean yes yes surely i mean i must have read a thousand articles in which african soldiers are looking out over the wall and this is a well they're they're in forts so clearly they are serving a kind of defensive purpose but the the wall is is seen as being more of a kind of you know customs marker or yeah we talked said before expression of power or something yeah that it's it's not a platform for actually uh defending against yeah barbarians so so to use your game of thrones analogy it's not people aren't wildlings aren't hurling themselves at the wall and being beaten back by is there any evidence of that did anybody ever attack the wall hadrian's
长城，是的，我们有关于人们袭击它、绕过它、突破它的记录，所以它一定有某种防御作用，但问题是是否有士兵在上面走来走去，我想这是一种刻板印象。那是你想象中发生的事情，但它备受争议。好吧，我想我们必须画一条线。筑起一道墙。我为你准备了一道墙，汤姆。你知道科茨洛墙（Cottesloe Wall）吗？
wall yeah we've got records of of people attacking it going uh going around it uh breaking through it um so it must have had some kind of defensive purpose but the the question is whether there were soldiers kind of walking up and down it which is is, I guess, the stereotype of it. That's what you imagine happened, but it's much debated. Well, I think we must draw a line. Draw a wall. I've got a wall for you, Tom. Do you know about the Cottesloe Wall?
不，我不知道。你知道牛津的科茨洛墙吗？谢丽尔·哈德逊（Cheryl Hudson）在推特上跟我们提到了这个，这是我最喜欢的墙之一，因为这对很多人来说非常惊讶。所以这是两堵墙，在牛津。所以谢丽尔·哈德逊在推特上跟我们提到了这个，这是我最喜欢的墙之一，因为这对很多人来说非常惊讶。所以这基本上是两堵墙，在20世纪30年代建于牛津，用来分隔中产阶级和工人阶级区域。所以基本上发生的事情是，一个开发商有权建造一批房屋，他竖起了一堵带刺的铁丝网墙，以阻止来自当地市议会经济适用房小区的居民试图闯入，这些墙保留了大约25年，它们极其
No, I don't. You know about the Cottesloe Walls in Oxford? So Cheryl Hudson tweeted us about this, and it's one of my favourite walls because this is very surprising to a lot of people. So these are two walls, Oxford. So Cheryl Hudson tweeted us about this and it's one of my favourite walls because this is very surprising to a lot of people. So these are two walls basically that went up in Oxford in the 1930s to separate the middle class and working class areas. So basically what happened was a developer had the right to build a load of houses and he put up a spiked wall to deter people from the local council estate from trying to get in and these walls stayed for about 25 years and they were incredibly
具争议性，我的意思是人们发起运动反对它们，1950年它们被拆除了，1959年……所以如果你在1958年去过牛津，你会发现一条街，你走着走着，街中间会有一堵带刺的墙，把市议会的租户挡在外面。这是合法的？是的。嗯，当时有巨大的法律斗争。这没完没了，开发商拒绝拆除。而市议会，你知道的，他们不断寻找漏洞，所以市议会无法强制执行。当然，很多人对此感到极度震惊。但当地的房主们全力支持它。他们不想让市议会……这只是发生在牛津的事情吗？
controversial i mean sort of people campaigned against them in 1950 they came down 1959 so if you'd gone to oxford in 1958 you'd have found a street where you'd walk along and there'd be a spiked wall in the middle of the street to keep the council tenants out. And this was legal? Yeah. Well, there were huge legal battles. It went on and on and the developers refused to take it down. And the council, you know, they kept finding loopholes so the council couldn't enforce it. And of course, a lot of people were hugely shocked by it. But the local homeowners were all for it. They didn't want the council to... And is this only something that happened in Oxford?
是的，我想是的。我的意思是，也许听众们知道其他这样的墙，但我觉得牛津……这证实了我对牛津更黑暗的猜疑。牛津。你是个剑桥人，对吧？对，我一点也不觉得奇怪。一点也不觉得奇怪。
Yes, I think so. I mean, maybe listeners will know of other such wars, but I think Oxford... That confirms my darker suspicions of Oxford. Of Oxford. You're a Cambridge man, aren't you? Yeah, I'm not surprised. Not surprised.
好吧，让我们在这个令人遗憾的烂摊子上画个句号。建一堵墙。结束这个播客。多米尼克和我将去执行世纪任务。非常感谢大家收听我们的节目。我们周四见。下次见。感谢收听《历史的余烬》（The Rest Is History）。若想收听独家番外、提前解锁、无广告收听以及加入我们的聊天社区，请访问 restishistorypod.com 注册。网址是 restishistorypod.com。本期节目暂无评论。点击文稿中的任意句子即可发表评论。
Well, let's draw a line under this whole sorry business. Build a wall. End this podcast. Dominic and I are going to go off and do some Century Duty. Thanks very much for listening to us. We'll be back on Thursday. See you next time. Thanks for listening to The Rest Is History. For bonus episodes, early access, ad-free listening, and access to our chat community, please sign up at restishistorypod.com. That's restishistorypod.com. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
好吧，让我们把这件令人遗憾的破事彻底翻篇吧。修堵墙，结束这个播客。我和多米尼克要去执行“世纪任务”了。非常感谢大家收听我们的节目。我们周四见。下次见。感谢收听《历史的剩余》。想要获取独家单集、提前收听、无广告体验以及加入我们的聊天社区，请访问 restishistorypod.com 注册。网址是 restishistorypod.com。本集目前还没有评论。点击文稿中的任意句子即可发表评论。